[Music]
it's finally a new edition of pftot i'm
back from a week at the beach and it
kind of feels like the beach in the
studio here because we got a little
issue with the air conditioning so i'm
going to try to get through today's
topics before i break into a full-blown
albert brooks in broadcast news flop
sweat let's start
with the deadline for
getting long-term deals done with
players who have been franchised tagged
there were three as of monday morning
but robbie gould the 49ers kicker has
his new contract so it's down to two
grady jared of the falcons reports
indicate that
there is optimism that a long-term deal
is in the offing for grady jarrett and
the atlanta falcons and then there's
jadavian clowney and the houston texans
all indications have been for a while
now the texans aren't interested in
signing him to a long-term deal so
they'll squat on him for one more year
at least making his career in houston a
minimum of six seasons and then next
year the texans will have to decide
whether or not to apply the franchise
tag will let him walk away and remember
today's deadline means only that
after july 15 there can be no multi-year
contracts between franchise tag players
and the teams that tag them also if a
player is traded he can't be signed to a
long-term deal it's a one-year contract
only now there can be more money there
can be other terms but it can only be a
one-year deal after today
that's the deadline today's the day the
window closes and there are far fewer
names and likely far less activity than
we've seen in past years when that
mid-july deadline rolls around
a lot of talk emerged on friday about
the possibility of an 18-game regular
season it's almost like the nfl
deliberately picked that day
to allow multiple reports to surface all
at the same time regarding this notion
that the nfl is very interested and has
remained interested for years in an 18
game regular season now once the nfl
became
actually concerned or at least
decided it was
in the best interest of the business to
act like it's concerned about player
health and safety i'm not here to say
which is which but once the nfl entered
that new territory eight nine years ago
it was impossible to reconcile an
expanded regular season with notions of
player health and safety but the league
has still wanted 18 games and the the
growth of legalized gambling only makes
the nfl want it more and now that the
cba negotiations are happening the nfl
is pushing for 18 games
the fans don't want it though we had a
poll that lasted two full days at pft
more than 44 000 votes 62 said keep it
at 16. now the permutations are fairly
simple 16 games or 17 games that's
packers ceo mark murphy's proposal the
one that is frankly my favorite 17 games
gives every team an international game
or a neutral sight game on american soil
and everyone would have eight home games
eight road games one neutral sight game
and no more eight nates you'd be nine
and eight or eight and eight unless of
course you have a tie
then you could possibly be eight eight
and one but you know the nfl is going to
continue to push for 18 games the
players have made it clear they don't
want it the question ultimately is this
do the players really not want it or are
they simply engaged in excellent
negotiating here making the nfl think
they don't want it forcing the nfl to
eventually make the players an offer
they can't refuse then the challenge for
the players
when do you accept that offer how many
offers do you refuse before you truly
can't refuse an offer do you overplay
your hand and blow it all together i
think there's a way to get the players
to play 18 games it's on the nfl to come
up with a proposal though to make that
happen and it has to be good enough that
the players can't say no and it also has
to be good enough that the players don't
push too hard so they want more than the
nfl is willing to pay to get those two
extra games now
one proposal that finally made its way
into the bargaining session that
happened last month the possibility of
18 games with a per player limit of 16.
that first surfaced via the wall street
journal on friday something that the nfl
has finally proposed but
i don't see this ever going anywhere
it's been lingering for years
and i knew there was a time where the
nfl was eventually going to float it out
there well so far it has failed every
test no one wants this fans don't want
it players don't want it media doesn't
want it the idea of players being
arbitrarily forced to sit out two games
a year
when they're otherwise healthy and able
to go that would wreak havoc on the
sport we've talked a lot about
unintended consequences as it relates to
replay review for past interference
there would be an immense number of
unintended consequences if players were
forced to sit out two games per year if
coaches were forced to figure out which
two games per year each player would
miss now injuries would take care of a
lot of it but still
you don't want to get yourself in that
position where fans have tickets to a
game and the reason a guy isn't playing
a guy they want to see play isn't
because he's injured but because this is
one of the two games per year that he
will miss so i don't see that ever
happening but the fact the proposal was
made just underscores how badly the nfl
wants to get to 18. they want to
increase the number of games that count
they want to shrink the preseason the
games that don't count increase the
games that do count as wagering on
sports continues to spread throughout
the country it's more and more and more
money that the nfl and the players will
make and again it all comes back to the
quality of the offer that the nfl will
make to the players at some point the
players won't be able to say no to an
18-game regular season and
the next opportunity for the two sides
to talk about 18 or 17 or some other
possibility as it relates to the current
structure of the season will be this
week cba talks are set to resume it will
be session number four now roger goodell
the nfl's commissioner made it clear
last week as pft first reported several
weeks back that the nfl definitely wants
to get a deal in place before the start
of the nfl's 100th season
it is impractical to think that will
happen and if the nfl really wants it
they're going to have to overpay and
this gets back to the same issue that
the players are dealing with with 18
games how hard do you push when you know
the nfl really wants it they really want
18 games how hard do you push to get
what you want in return the nfl wants to
get a cba by the start of the season how
hard do you push do you push too far
where's that sweet spot where you know
you are getting a premium for giving the
nfl what it wants by way of having a
deal in place by the start of the season
but you're not pushing so hard that you
blow the whole thing up that's the
reality here the players have additional
leverage
if they get a deal done now
that leverage goes away that ability to
do a better deal than maybe they would
be able to do a year from now that's
gone if they blow this opportunity and
look i'm not saying that they should or
shouldn't take advantage of this chance
all i'm saying is there is an
opportunity here to get more than maybe
you could get a year from now by pushing
forward at the league's behalf to get a
deal done because if one side wants to
get it done now
there's value in that to the other side
and we'll see if the two sides can
negotiate something that would get done
by the start of the regular season again
i don't think it's practical because
for a variety of reasons not the least
of which is this
you've got
90 players per roster a lot harder to
get the votes in place to approve a cba
before the rosters cut to 53 and when
they cut to 53 on august 30 you only
have a few days before the start of the
regular season to get all the teams to
vote you're going to have to sell this
to a lot of guys quickly in order to
make it happen by the start of the
regular season so that's why i don't
think it's realistic now i could see a
deal in principle
before the start of the regular season
that just gets approved over the course
of the first several weeks of the season
but again you got to get the teams on
board i don't think the nflpa wants
another situation where an entire team
like the steelers rejects completely and
totally the cba that was negotiated by
union leadership
peyton manning has continued to reject
all overtures from tv most recently he
said no to monday night football again
and peyton manning has talked about why
he didn't do it and charles robinson of
yahoo had a report over the weekend
about why peyton didn't do it bottom
line is he doesn't want to have to
analyze slash criticize his brother eli
manning and also for the first time this
notion of peyton manning not wanting to
have to analyze and criticize former
teammates is coming to the fore and i
get it i respect that now look
i think there's a way to do the job
without
saying things that could anger people
but i respect peyton manning's
desire to do the job right and the only
way you do the job right is if you say
what you believe even if that means
potentially pissing some people off and
i know from experience 19 years in what
i do you
pretend to piss a lot of people off if
you tell what you think is the truth
peyton manning wants to be able when he
does take a tv job if he ever takes a tv
job to say what he believes to tell the
truth as he sees it and uh to not have
to worry about the consequences whatever
they may be so
peyton manning at least will continue to
say no to tv until his brother retires
and then after that he may wait for a
few former teammates to walk away and
ultimately you know he mentioned jets
coach adam gase because he worked
closely with him in denver it could be
that he waits until gace isn't coaching
before peyton manning jumps into tv
either way tv's always going to be there
they're not going to turn their back on
peyton manning whenever he's ready to go
there will be one or more networks ready
to move heaven and earth and pay him a
crapload of money and let him dictate
the terms of who the broadcast team will
be and who he'll be working with and
what he'll be doing all in the hopes of
getting peyton manning as part of that
network's coverage because the belief is
he'll be the best ever better than john
madden better than tony romo better than
anybody if and when peyton manning
finally chooses to do it all right last
one story that popped up last week good
time to get attention
uh because it was kind of toward the end
of the slow time this offseason melvin
gordon the chargers running back wanting
his new contract willing to hold out
willing to demand a trade willing to sit
out into the regular season we'll see
about all of that we'll see what happens
if and when the chargers don't give
gordon what he wants bottom line is he's
in the final year of a rookie contract
he's due to make 5.605 million this year
he wants to get paid more than that and
the reality is running backs the supply
outweighs the demand and only the truly
special running backs get paid huge
money melvin gordon does not fall into
that category of truly special so i i
think and i'm a big this is tough for me
i'm a big believer
and players taking a stand and players
disrupting the system and players saying
give me what i deserve the problem is if
you over play your hand when you take
that stand it blows up in your face so
it could be that melvin gordon like
remember when maurice jones drew sat out
all of the off season all of not all the
offseason but all the training camp in
the preseason and then caved that could
be what happens with melvin gordon if
you over play it and then you have to
cave where are you
if the team doesn't waive the fines that
you incur during
pre-season during training camp you end
up out a lot of money and you have
nothing to show for it you have to
continue to wait for your shot at the
open market so that's the downside for
melvin gordon because he's not one of
the truly special running backs in the
nfl if he does hold out there may end up
being no easy way out of this for him
all right that's it for today's pft ot i
think i made it through
without completely melting we got to get
the folks here to fix this air
conditioning though it is extremely warm
inside it's extremely warm outside enjoy
the rest of the day it's a hot one it's
a very hot one right here and it's going
to continue to stay hot for the rest of
the summer but things are heating up for
the national football league training
camps open soon we're with you every day
this week with an edition of pftot and
only two weeks until pft live returns
july 29 6 to 9 a.m eastern on nbc sports
radio with four hours of simulcast on
nbcsn it's complicated we'll figure it
out later we'll tell you how it's all
going to work and i'll see you again
here tomorrow
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports